خطر داهم يقترب مع اقتراب عطله نهايه
السنه القمريه في الصين
سفر الملايين من الصينيين سواء داخل او
خارج البلاد بعد التزايد المضطرد في حالات
كورونا جراء رفع بكين الاجراءات
الاحترازيه الصارمه التي فرضتها خلال
الجائحه
المستشفيات امتلات بمصابي كورونا وامكانيه
السفر الصينيين او اشخاص قادمين من الصين
الى مختلف ارجاء العالم تسببت في ردات فعل
على المستوى الدولي
ليه
ليهلين انضمت الى باريس في الزمام
القادمين من الصين باثبات خلوهم من
الفيروس باجراء اختبار الكوفيد كما نصح
عدد من الدول الاوروبيه مواطنيها بتجنب
السفر غير الضروري الى الصين
وما يثير المخاوفه وتعبير منظمه الصحه
العالميه عن شكلها في الاحصائيات التي
تقدمها بكين متهمه اياها بعدم تقديم صوره
واضحه للوضع الوبائي في بلد تعداده فوق
المليارا واربعه 100 مليون نسمه تضاف الى
ذلك اتهامات لبكينا بعدم الشفافيه فيما
يتعلق بظهور متحورات جديده